hey at seven I believe it's important to
thank the people who have helped you in
your business get to where you are show
some gratitude and every week I make a
new video thanking someone who's helped
me so today i want to thank guy kawasaki
when I was first starting my website I
had a bunch of famous stories famous
entrepreneur stories on my site and a
few friends of mine who were business
coaches & consultants wrote in to save
they can add content to and I thought
maybe there's a model here maybe I can
get more people on board to contribute
some stuff on my website it could be
great resource for entrepreneurs but I
wasn't coming to the model didn't know
if it'd work out or not and in the
friend of mine new guy and introduced us
and I send a quick email to him saying
basically asked him he would be part of
my website you know we could take some
articles and his and post it on the site
I think the email is pretty weak but but
I had some passion to it and he wrote
back to say I trust you let's do it and
that for me gave me confidence that hey
this is something that people are
interested in and I could really blow
this up and from there we've gone on now
I have 7,000 people contributing to the
website we fight over 20 million people
check it out helping tons of
entrepreneurs and a lot of that can be
traced back to guys saying yeah count me
in i'm on board and i gave me a huge
confidence boost to go out and do this a
couple years later I wanted to create a
line of famous entrepreneur trading
cards I'm a huge baseball card fan
growing up I've got thousands of cards
and I wanted to create my own line and
do it for charity and I thought if we
partner up with bloggers who are
well-known in their field and ask them
to pick their favorite famous
entrepreneur I'd make a baseball card of
them so the famous on turns on the front
and the bloggers on the back and any
money we made from it would go to
support entrepreneurs in Africa through
a program called KIBRA that I'm I'm a
believer so I had the idea i partnered
up with the company to do it and I said
okay how am I gonna start this I got to
turn the guy and I thought you know what
I'm not going to commit to this or not
but I'm going to write the guy and if
he's on board because I
the Steve Jobs card and I knew that he
was a big fan of jobs if guy was on
board them then we're ago because I
could use that to then go out and get
other bloggers and create a whole line
of cards so i wrote to i wrote the guide
was a few days you know I've gone by I
hadn't or anything back I was warning
you know maybe maybe didn't get to him
or maybe maybe he's not interested in it
because he usually writes back to the
emails and then I remember I was driving
one day I was going to go buy a new
stroller I'm in the car on the passenger
and i look at my phone and email from
guy comes in about the car is a call
this is it let's see what he says i hope
this is a hope we had says yes and i
don't remember exactly what he wrote but
basically he was on board he said let's
do it he's excited let's do it count me
in for the project and like it's a go
this is great and i called up the
company was working with and said we're
on board let's get this going let's make
the first card and then we can explain
it to all the other ones and so again i
was at this you know point of maybe i'll
do it maybe I won't let see what guy
says and he he gave me the vote of
confidence and and I created that line
and as a result we brought on a number
of bloggers they all picked their
favorite famous entrepreneurs we started
selling the cards and we have helped
3500 entrepreneurs in Africa get their
businesses started because of the
proceeds that we've raised through
selling the cars went to the website and
so again it was a great project that
meant a lot to me as a passion project I
got the crib my own line of baseball
cards around entrepreneurs and help
raise money for a great cause and again
guy was instrumental in helping set that
up just by saying yes and just bye-bye
you know being involved at the early
stages and given a confidence booster to
let me know that hey you know this is
interesting and people will want to be
involved so thank you God you know I
don't know if I ever told you those
stories but it means a lot it has helped
my business grow in a number of
different directions and I don't know if
I would have gone that path if if you
didn't give me that vote of confidence
in the early days so thank you so much
and for everybody watching take time
today to thank somebody who's had an
impact on your business it'll make you
feel good and make them feel good and it
will help your business grow if you guys
like this video please give
thumbs up below and I'd love to hear
what you have to think about this video
in the comments love seen the comments
thank you guys and you have a question
for your business leave it in the
section below and I'll do a video
response to you I will see you soon